We’ve covered a lot of SCPs on this channel,
but trust us, none of them have quite the
bite that this one does.
We know you like the more intellectual anomalies,
and this will give you plenty to chew on in
that regard.
While the SCP Foundation wants to keep SCP-5940
a secret, here at SCP Explained, we’re going
to give you the tooth, the whole tooth, and
nothing but the tooth.
Uh, truth.
I meant truth.
This SCP thankfully isn’t as existentially
threatening as a lot of the other ones we
cover, but just because it won’t send you
on an express trip to the pearly gates doesn’t
mean it won’t wreak havoc on your pearly
whites.
Open wide and say “Aaaah”, because today
we’re getting into an anomaly that affects
each and every one of us.
Tell us: Have you ever felt anxious about
your teeth?
Ever had that weird dream where all your teeth
fall out, or even worse, somebody pulls them
out?
Does the thought of us taking a hammer to
your teeth, or them rotting away someday and
making you need dentures, make you shudder
and cringe?
Don’t be ashamed: The answer to this question
for most people would be a resounding Yes,
and that’s because of humanity’s shared
PsychoDental Trauma.
Don’t know what that is?
That’s fine too.
After all, the Foundation has taken pains
to hide all this from you, for fear that even
knowing about it might incur further PsychoDental
stress.
It’s that kind of subtle but constant creeping
dread you experience in a dentist’s waiting
room, knowing it’s been too long since the
last time you came in, and now, you’re fully
anticipating him saying something like “Well,
it’s a real mess in here.
I’m afraid we’re going to have to take
them all, and I’m going to charge you double
just because they look so unpleasant.”
If that feels grimly familiar to you, then
you know exactly what we’re talking about
today.
The SCP Foundation searched long and hard
to find the source of this peculiar collective
trauma - Which, ironically, is a major factor
in people not actually visiting the dentist
more often - and has found the source in question
to be as ancient as it is strange.
To best explain exactly what we’re dealing
with here, we need to take a trip to the North
Pole - though we’re sorry to tell you that
today’s SCP is not, in fact, Santa’s Workshop.
It’s actually the Northern-most point of
inaccessibility, a part of the world that’s
nearly impossible to reach, simply by virtue
of being the cluster of Arctic ice pack furthest
away from any landmass, always moving and
shifting.
But if through some means you were ever able
to make your way up there, you would find
an impossibly large pair of maxillary incisors
- which, in layman's terms, is a giant pair
of front teeth.
So while there may not be Santa’s Grotto
up there, if all you want for Christmas is
your two front teeth, then buddy, you’re
in luck.
Incidentally, these two giant teeth, embedded
into the ground and dubbed SCP-5940 by the
SCP Foundation, are connected to the two front
teeth of every human being on earth.
Think of it almost like a pair of giant voodoo
dolls, but their effects on each individual
human are relatively mild.
That’s because the effects are actually
distributed across all humans, and the more
humans there are, the less damage to the enormous
pair of teeth will affect each of us.
The problem is, humans have eight incisors
- they’re the two sets of four front teeth
on the upper and lower jaw - and this pair
of teeth covers only two of them.
What about the rest?
Well, next on our roster is SCP-5940-2.
Let’s join intrepid scientist and explorer
Dr. John E. Namel - who has no affiliation
with the SCP Foundation - on his quest to
find them.
Dr. Namel and his small team braved brutal
colds and obscene treks through ice and snow
to finally discover this grand creation near
the southern pole of inaccessibility, the
point of Antarctica furthest away from the
Southern Ocean.
When he and his men finally arrived, they
gazed upon the incredible pair of teeth in
awe, a mighty set of mandibular central incisors
- otherwise known as the front teeth on the
bottom jaw.
The Foundation believes that the only way
to truly solve the problems that SCP-5940
poses is to remove the various teeth from
the areas where they’re currently lodged.
However, the Foundation doesn’t yet possess
the technology or resources to properly dislodge
any of these behemoths.
However, the psychic anticipation of the impending
tooth removal has caused the PsychoDental
trauma of people all over the world to skyrocket
in the meantime.
In a sense, it’s like the entire world is
sitting outside the dentist’s office, waiting
for a prognosis and hoping that when the dentist
pulls out their pair of surgical pliers, they
at least have the decency to give us a hit
of the laughing gas first.
However, the Foundation has discovered an
interesting fact in the meantime: The effects
of the teeth on the global population can
be slightly mitigated by enacting certain
forms of concussive trauma on them.
And to perform this act for the greater good
of the earth’s PsychoDental condition, Dr.
John E. Namel and those accompanying him made
the ultimate sacrifice.
Knowing, on a subconscious level, what they
must do, they began to turn their equipment
into a kind of makeshift diving board above
the giant incisors.
Once the board was complete, the adventurers
each took turns jumping off of it, gaining
speed as they rocketed down towards the teeth
below.
As each of them hit the sharp upper edges
of the teeth, they were cut in half, leaving
a smear of red against that shining white
calcium.
The two halves of their bisected bodies fell
down into the piles of frozen bones on either
side of the teeth’s base, all that remained
of prior brave heroes who’d made their final
pilgrimage to the site of SCP-5940.
While none of these various expeditions were,
in any way, officially related to the SCP
Foundation, the Foundation nonetheless extended
honorary Foundation Stars of Merit to those
who decided to take the plunge for the collective
PsychoDental health of their fellow man.
For SCP-5940-3, we have to go deeper.
Literally.
It’s at the bottom of the ocean.
Namely, it sits below Point Nemo - also known
as the Oceanic Point of Inaccessibility, the
furthest point away from land in the entire
world’s oceans.
This next absurd pair of teeth, some mandibular
lateral incisors, lurk below the churning
ocean waves, like a...Well, there’s nothing
really like a giant pair of underwater teeth,
is there?
Thankfully, the position of these teeth has
been serendipitous.
Not only does their remoteness make them much
harder for civilians to just stumble upon,
but Point Nemo has also always been a popular
spacecraft graveyard.
This means that, during tests and sometimes
even actual missions, the return trips are
often plotted towards Point Nemo to prevent
the risk of any errant spacecraft pieces from
landing in populated areas and causing damage
or death.
Remember we mentioned earlier that the Foundation
encourages repeated concussive attacks against
the teeth to ward off their PsychoDental effects?
Here, the pieces of spacecraft blasting into
the water towards them fulfill that role.
At the latest measurement, 126 of the 263
spacecraft ditched at this pole since 1971
had successfully collided with this particular
pair of teeth, giving them perhaps the weakest
output of PsychoDental trauma of any of the
SCP-5940 instances.
And while the furthest point in the ocean
from any major land masses may seem about
as remote as it gets, the last instance of
SCP-5940 easily blows it out of the water.
Well...Not literally, but if it did, that
would be a wonderful example of a problem
taking care of itself, wouldn’t it?
The last instance is SCP-5940, SCP-5940-4,
a pair of maxillary lateral incisors, live
on the dark side of the Moon.
Yep, dentists and Pink Floyd fans of the world
rejoice.
You’re probably wondering: While the first
three pairs of teeth clearly grew on Earth,
why is the fourth a pair of more lunar incisors?
Studies performed by the Foundation on the
soil around the base of the fourth set of
teeth prove that they did actually originate
on Earth.
They are believed to have split from Earth
during the incident which formed the Moon.
This means that these teeth are literally
older than the Moon, and this also makes them
billions of years older than humanity.
So these giant teeth don’t look like our
incisors - Our incisors look like these giant
teeth.
So now we finally understand this ridiculous
threat to our collective PsychoDental health.
Move over, SCP-682.
Step aside, Devourer of Worlds.
Get the hell out of my face, Scarlet King!
We can’t deal with any of you small-timers
until we’ve solved the Global PsychoDental
crisis posed by SCP-5940.
Which elite heavy-hitters have the Foundation
put on the case to deal with these enamel
nightmares?
Meet the Department of Psychodentistry, a
joint venture formed from the collaboration
of the Psionics Division - a task force that
specializes in psychic SCPs - the Department
of Memetics, and most importantly of all,
the Dentistry Division.
You may be thinking, “Why does the SCP Foundation
even need a Dentistry Division?
That seems like a waste of time and resources.”
And if you are thinking that, you’re not
only wrong, you probably have horrible teeth.
The Dentistry Division is the first and last
line of defense that the Foundation has against
a plethora of toothy anomalies.
Like SCP-5852, a strange phenomenon that causes
human teeth to grow out of the bodies of Cicadas.
Or SCP-2450, a condition that causes hyperdontia
- the excessive development of teeth - all
over the bodies of mammalian creatures, with
the infection being spread, appropriately,
through bites.
And of course, SCP-478, a terrifying predatory
moth-like creature that enters the bodies
of victims under the age of 25, and attaches
itself to the soft palate in the upper nasal
cavity.
From there, it would promote the unchecked
growth of teeth on the soft palate of the
victim, but that’s just where it starts.
Teeth develop all through the mouth, nasal
cavity, esophagus, and even the interior of
the stomach, where the digestion of the teeth
leads to excruciating pain.
Next time your entire body is filling up with
teeth due to SCP-478, you’ll really regret
underestimating the value of the humble Dentistry
Division.
So, what does the new Department of Psychodentistry
propose to do with SCP-5940, the ultimate
in tooth-based anomalies?
Thankfully, they have a plan that’ll unfold
over the next 79 years, known as the ABSOLUTE
TOOTH FIELD - in all upper-case letters.
It’s a three-pronged plan that’s sure
to fully neutralize this dental menace.
You see, there’s one thing we haven’t
told you: The psionic relationship between
the SCP-5940 and the incisors of all of humanity
isn’t one way.
While the giant teeth and what happens to
them can affect our teeth, what happens to
our teeth can also affect the nature of SCP-5940.
And that little fact is the key to the ABSOLUTE
TOOTH FIELD plan.
The first part of the plan involves using
memetics to make humans shun birth control
globally, accelerating population growth to
4.2% per year for the next 79 years - this
will lead to a population of 200 billion humans
by the year 2100.
The second part will be using memetics to
encourage every human to somehow mechanically
remove all of their incisors, and the third
part will be the most complicated of all:
Trying to get all these 200 billion humans
to remove the same incisors at the same time.
The Department of Psychodentistry estimates
that this will create the sufficient psychic
force to finally pull the various SCP-5940
instances from their moorings, and thus healing
humanity’s collective Psychodental trauma.
It’s a brilliant plan to take out a dangerous
anomaly, and surely one-trillion-six-hundred-billion
human incisors is a small price to pay.
Now go check out “Waldo Finds You - SCP-4885
- Find Him” and “SCP-2430 - Immortal Hitler
Clone” for more of the absolute weirdest
anomalies out there!
Oh, and uh, remember to brush your teeth twice
a day.
You’ll thank us later for that.